[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone and welcome to the iron
lords podcast
first look at this game that we like to
call
pumpkin jack now pumpkin jack was a game
that we first
originally heard about in
2020 from our friends over at
wiki games and they told us that we
really really really should take the
time
to go ahead and look into this game
because it was
amazing for them to play at pax east
well
we finally got our hands on a copy and
we wanted to make sure that we
give our little bit of our input into
this game
to you all here now pumpkin jack is a
game
where you play as this scarecrow a scare
crow called jack uh he is a
dead individual who is brought back to
life save the world
as per what you'd expect now you are
specifically now the pumpkin head is
jacks
thoughts memories all of that fun stuff
and now
some points throughout the whole entire
game this is something very important
for you to know
because you end up taking yourself into
different parts of your world meaning
you do your combat you're running and
you're fighting and
against other creatures with the full
scarecrow body
or you're placed into this pumpkin form
where you're
placed to make sure that you work on
puzzles and fix
things now i really really really
loved this game it was not was
not as is expected for me to walk into
it and
feel how enjoyable it was uh now
um graphically the game was
very very vivid the the colors on it
were
beautiful my eyes were not tired i loved
it
it was great every single level from
from the first level to the second to
the third
you felt like they increased the
capabilities of this
of this graphical interface with
everything around you the creatures the
monsters
the whole backdrop i i really really
thought that they did a fantastic job
with that
now the other thing that that i feel
about this game that was really really
nice was
the controls the controls were very very
clean and solid
you would have expected them through any
type of puzzle game
that you would have thought of you know
you have that third person view from
right right behind them
just like dexter and jack and things and
games like that
that you'd want to be like want to be
able to do you all you're being able to
look around
kind of the way that assassin's creed is
now when you're looking from behind
the the character you use this crow on
your shoulder
to be able to knock creatures from a
distance
you get multiple different weapons that
were
it was so cool each weapon that you get
is unique
to the combat style as your own we got
the sword we got the spear we got the
uh we got the regular uh shovel we had
all those really really cool things to
play with and it was really really nice
um throughout the whole entire map uh
you end up
also being able to find secret little
easter eggs throughout the whole entire
map
and those maps i'm sorry and those
easter eggs would then allow you to
hand those in for new types of clothing
for for jack
to be running around with now uh the
replayability in this game is pretty
good
uh the puzzles um that i went through
were were not super complex but they
were
complex enough that i would probably
forget them pretty pretty quickly
and then i would have to go back and you
know start doing the puzzle
and then once i started remembering what
the puzzle was and then i would probably
have gone right back into it
but the game itself was so much fun i
could see myself wanting to go back and
doing that
so that was pretty pretty cool
um now the other thing like i was saying
is uh the puzzles
which i think are a huge uh step up in
the game which is really really nice
um the puzzles uh they that you had to
do
were to where you took your head off
and you ended up placing it on the
ground and then you kind of like have
these little sprouts come up and then
you go into like
a place where your scarecrow body
wouldn't be able to go died for less
and then you'd be having to fix these
puzzles now
the first puzzle they kind of show you
uh which is in
in the video it's very very easy but
later on you get very very
complicated puzzles which i really
really like i'm one of those people that
love puzzles
just like uh you know breath of the wild
uh you're going through puzzles and
things like that and i love it
so i was i was excited to play them and
see how complicated they were
but at the same time they have this
simplistic
nature that you know you could have
somebody else
of uh you know a lot younger be able to
take the controls and figure them out uh
with a little bit of time
and it was and it was really really cool
uh the the
storyline and the whole entire game was
great um i don't want to give out any
out any information other than what i
did but i thought they did a really
really good job with that going from
boss to boss the boss
the difficulty level of each boss going
from boss to boss to boss was great
i thought that they did a great job uh i
really
hope that they end up coming out with
another version of
of uh you know of pumpkin jack to uh to
allow other people to
to to see it uh make sure you guys are
growing up on steam and picking it up i
highly recommend
you going in there and giving it a go
playing with it
it's great i love it you guys should
definitely check it out
so um yeah so thank you very much for
uh giving us this copy of pumpkin jack
and we will end up
talking to you guys later thank you very
much and remember uh
make sure you go into uh lords of
gaming.net for all of your
gaming information and check out the
ironwood's podcast every single sunday
where we end up talking about the
present you know
top gaming news of the week all right
thank you very much
and have a fantastic day bye everybody
interesting interesting
all right so i guess we're gonna go
towards the cauldron
get running start then double jump
across the bridge
is there a way to like sprint not so far
jack
you've shaken off those cobwebs well
it does feel good to have your own body
again arms legs and everything
you really put them into the tests from
the here
there will be monsters ahead you
shouldn't have any trouble fighting them
off
bash some heads why should they attack
me
they can't be told anything jack
monsters are
mostly mindless miss screens they could
barely
tell each other apart let alone
something like you
pumpkin or not you're still human and
alone makes him your target
so that's why the devil needs me he
needs someone who can think like a man
this new enemy is clever jack and needs
someone
just as clever trickster nonetheless
i'm cutting down his monsters they're
practically worse
okay
dodge attacks be okay
as you can tell
did
the girls aren't supposed to have legs
if you help us in return at the mercy of
a crow
what do you want a scarecrow often
appears at the barn just ahead
he's been terrorizing us for weeks using
minutes to crochet
get rid of the crow
some air support will be useful very
well bird
oh is this the crow that you were
talking about
left bumper what
uh cool
this is pretty amazing
i like the music change
i'm gonna take that over here
what is this shovel for my friend grab
oh
i got a shovel and i know how to use it
there buddy
really did you did you finish it or did
you get far
or did they just give you a couple of
cool things
oh
oh yeah i beat it in two nights
if they're there what they sent me the
code oh really
they sent me the first code they
released because
we had a blast of packs okay do you know
how long it takes to beat it
oh five to eight hours really
eight of you spend time searching for
the hidden crosstalk okay
oh
[Music]
oh
this music is pretty cool
this crow is the awesome
boom
yeah i mean i don't i don't intend to go
looking around for
for that stuff what is this dude
don't hurt me
yes don't hurt me sir oh sure you look
like a monster to me
rotten half dead soulless of course i'm
a salesman
browse my wares what are you selling
skins i harvest skins of interesting
debut
i'll kill you but i want a discount by
all means
please take a look
the samurai
is this what all those skulls are for i
guess
oh that would be cool if it ended up
continuing to burn
based on everything else that's cool i
busted that barrel and it's on the tree
that's pretty neat
there's a monster essence somewhere by
now break
stuff to restore your health in a pinch
yeah yeah
i figured that one out
no
boom
so you're naturally gonna be able to
pick stuff up too as you're running
through everything
which is not too shabby we're gonna
break these so we can run
we're gonna run oh bert i got a question
for you bud
did you ever watch um
hunter x hunter
because i know you're like me you've
watched a lot of the old school stuff
you did
in comparison to huhu haga show which
did you
think was better
because i know you've seen both
really
i have a bunch of people that are
usually on my stream that usually say
that hunter x hunter is like
the best one out of all of them because
it's more in depth
uh
i need a better weapon than the shovel i
need something that does more damage
it's made by the same person but they're
pretty much a filter
a filler oh
if they ever get back to releasing
episodes i'm sure
you're gonna watch them but it's always
a favorite all the time
really
see i i watch a lot
like a lot and
i feel like all of them are really
really different
really you got a demonstrator tattoo
that's that's probably one of my
favorites
all right can't go that's out of bounds
that looks like a heart
looks a little bit like a heart
i didn't know you were that much into
demon slur also
your new body isn't needed here
hop out for a minute and take a look
inside
use your head
kramen bird
i agree
what
[Music]
black clover is pretty good yeah
right now i say black clover is one of
the betters
um that are out right now
oh wow this is awesome
um i think they did a really they're
doing a really really good job with it
uh i really really love
um what is it called
hunt i really i'm loving uh
um
oh i'm really loving those two
hmm uh
i bet you i wasn't supposed to do this
yet
and it's supposed to go this way
there we go did you just send me a
picture
of the tattoo
interesting
dude how many do you have
i knew you had a couple i didn't know
you had that many though
oh i was not watching where i was going
ah i'm not good at platformers
whatsoever
like 20
open sesame
but like see like i've always been a
huge fan of sao
even though i like everyone's like it's
like the worst anime ever to watch
what are you doing because i really
enjoy
the that whole concept of how they did
that
um but like i really love that show i
really love
uh israel to pick up a girl in dungeon
which
people are like why would you love that
one but like demon slayer
is definitely one of my
top also
and hunter x hunters it's i think that
the way they're doing the story is
actually pretty solid and i'm kind of
liking that
dude have you ever played have you ever
seen the dot hat
hack shows in movies
oh my god
oh my god i want to do the spin i can't
move
my god i'm getting old
losing my hannah no you gave up on him
the the shows are actually pretty
they're pretty decent
i'm not saying like they're like the
best shows in the known world but
they're still pretty good
um
attack attack at that all right there
good here
any more essence to health or whatever
because i'm a dumb dumb
let's see here
see i'm not even done with it yet i'm
only like 20 or so episodes in
right well that was the thing that was
interesting about
like sao it was on this hiatus for so
long
and then the writer kind of like finally
started making more
um episodes so people started getting
pulled and sucked back in
so we're gonna go up here and jump up
here
oh no
but i'm really disappointed that this
like
demon slayer has been on a hiatus for
this long
like i know that their intention is like
make a movie and all but like come on
like
you guys gotta get moving here even
though it's so good like i feel like the
hype is gonna like lose it's cool soon
all right we gotta kill some more
oh my god
whoa
well yeah they were saying spring
but i thought it was supposed to come
out like like december this year
and then we end up we still haven't seen
it yet
everything's getting pushed back
black clover is it supposed to have a
movie also
i think they may have had one i don't
remember
oh i don't know because i don't remember
having a movie but it's the show's back
on
because i watch them all subtitled i
don't watch them with the dubbed
i prefer it that way
no
i need to go to get some food so bad
but i need to see you get to the end of
the first level
is it long
i'm trying to push through it quick if
it makes you feel any better
almost done uh am i supposed to go this
way
that's where i came in
yeah i don't remember passing any of
these dudes
there we go
oh where did your dude come from
a little bit like the bird going to and
from you is like a recharge timer
do you smell smoke
i gotta get the flap out of here
all right this is pretty good
this gives me like assassin's creed
feels
what the flock
i'm running
it does mess with your eyes
go bird go
that was pretty cool
that is a pretty damn long
thing though
that was the end of packs
but did they like show you like the end
level or something you were saying
a little scarecrow oh this is a
scarecrow you're probably gonna fight it
who goes there shoot yourself there it
is
call just messing as always
don't be so caring
did what a monster is not going on oh
i won't busy scarecrow if you don't mind
getting out of my way i don't mind
turning you into kiddling
the devil is doing a job
i'll bury you again you wretch oh boy
what these are the guys that are gonna
kill me
more so than the stupid scarecrow you
realize that right
it's gonna probably do the shooting
thing again
knock him down
hit him up oh stay distance from him
i see puff smoke out of his behind
i want to see what this bird can do
later on because i remember you saying
that
the bird gets bigger
i wonder if it's a three shot dealer or
more
yeah yeah
oh that's cool
we got a cool spear dingy jack the
genius trickster who could fool even the
devil himself
has returned to the mortal realm
armed with a brand new body and is so
cruelly bound to a festering pumpkin
jack has been joined by his stoic guide
the hour
and commandeered the services of a
cowardly
there must be owl more time for funny
games
jack and his companions of the night
must embark upon their quest
to slay the wizard with jack now
perfectly attuned to his new vessel
the owl leads him to the mountains in
the distance or at the heart of the
mountains
through a network of ancient mines
[Music]
you